>>> AND WELCOME BACK TO OUR LIVE
COVERAGE FROM LVIV, UKRAINE.
WE HAD A SLIGHT TECHNICAL
PROBLEM.
WE SEEMED TO HAVE WORKED THAT
OUT.
APOLOGIES.
IT HAPPENS.
WE WANT TO GET PERSPECTIVE FROM
WHAT WE'VE SEEN TODAY AND THE
PAST TWO WEEKS AND WHAT WE MAY
SEE TOMORROW.
DAVID REMNICK, AUTHOR OF SIX
BOOK, INCLUDING "THE
INDISPENSABLE LENIN'S TOMB."
YOU HEAR MATTHEW CHANCE TALKING
ABOUT THE MEETING BETWEEN THE
UKRAINIAN FOREIGN MINISTER AND
RUSSIA.
WE'VE SEEN SOME EVIDENCE OF
CORRIDORS THAT HAVE BEEN OPEN.
WE'VE SEEN OTHER VIOLATIONS OF
THAT, BOTH SIDES BLAMING EACH
OTHER FOR THAT.
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE THAT YOU
SEE THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN WANTS AN
END TO THIS WAR AT THIS POINT?
>> NOT YET.
I MEAN, LET'S STIPULATE THAT
THIS IS AN INVASION OF A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY FOR NO REASON
AT ALL, AND IT'S BEEN MERCILESS
AND DISGUSTING AND BRUTAL.
SO, THAT'S -- THAT'S THE THING
THAT'S MOST OBVIOUS.
AND -- AND YET WE'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE DON'T WANT IT
TO ESCALATE TO THE POINT WHERE
UKRAINE IS DECIMATED AND JUST
ENDLESS CASUALTIES AND REFUGEE
CRISIS THAT DESTABILIZES EUROPE
FOR THE REST OF OUR LIVES.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT.
AND THE ANCIENT PHILOSOPHER ONCE
SAID THAT YOU NEED TO BUILD A
GOLDEN BRIDGE, A GOLDEN BRIDGE,
FOR YOUR OPPONENT, FOR YOUR
ENEMY, SO THAT HE CAN WALK
ACROSS AND RETREAT.
AND SOMEHOW, SOME WAY, UKRAINE
IS GOING TO HAVE TO DEVISE --
AND ABOVE ALL UKRAINE.
THE WEST CAN'T DO IT FOR
UKRAINE.
SOME SENSE OF WHAT CAN BE
CONCEDED, AS PAINFUL AND
HORRIBLE AND UNJUST AS IT IS, SO
THAT THERE'S A NEGOTIATED
SETTLEMENT, SO THAT THIS INSANE
WAR, INSTIGATED SOLELY BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN CAN END AND THE
BLOODSHED CAN END.
AND THESE CONCESSIONS WILL BE
ENORMOUSLY PAINFUL, WHETHER IT'S
RECOGNIZING CRIMEA, FINALLY, AS
RUSSIAN TERRITORY OR SOME
SETTLEMENT IN EAST OF UKRAINE.
I TOTALLY RECOGNIZE THIS IS
SOVEREIGN UKRAINIAN TERRITORY.
BUT THERE'S NO SIGN YET THAT
PUTIN IS -- JUST BECAUSE HE'S
SUFFERED SOME MILITARY LOSSES IN
SOME PARTS OF THE COUNTRY, THAT
HE'S GOING TO JUST MERELY
RETREAT.
THAT'S NOT HIM.
THAT'S NOT HIS HISTORY.
IT WASN'T IN SYRIA.
>> YEAH.
AND I MEAN, YOU'VE CERTAINLY
SEEN -- YOU KNOW, WE'VE ALL SEEN
WHAT THE RUSSIAN MILITARY IS
CAPABLE OF DOING IN GROEZNY, IN
ALEPPO, IN SYRIA, LEVELING
GROSSI ESSENTIAL AND INSTALLING
A THUG AS A LEADER THERE.
HAVE YOU BEEN SURPRISED AT THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY?
>> WELL, I THINK PUTIN IS
SURPRISED AT THE PERFORMANCE OF
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY.
WHAT HAPPENS IN AN AUTHORITARIAN
REGIME AND PUTIN'S REGIME IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BECOME MORE
AND MORE DESPOTIC YEAR AFTER
YEAR, AS HE BECOMES INCREASINGLY
ISOLATED.
HE BEGINS TO BELIEVE HIS OWN
NONSENSE.
FEWER AND FEWER PEOPLE COME TO
THE DESK WITH CONTRARY
INFORMATION.
AND HE CLEARLY THOUGHT HE COULD
WALTZ INTO UKRAINE AND IN A FEW
DAY'S TIME EITHER INSTALL A
PUPPET REGIME OR HAVE THEM GIVE
UP.
AND UKRAINE HAS PROVEN ITSELF
WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF
ZELENSKYY, AND THE SHEER
BRILLIANCE OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE, THEY HAVE PROVED
THEMSELVES CAPABLE, AT LEAST
UNTIL NOW, OF FENDING OFF THE
RUSSIANS.
BUT LET'S NOT BE DILUTED.
LET'S NOT BE DILUTED.
YES, THE ATTACK ON KYIV HAS BEEN
STALLED.
BUT RUSSIA, THROUGH SHEER
BRUTALISM, IS -- IS MAKING
ENORMOUS GAINS IN THE SOUTH
ALONG THE BLACK SEA.
AND, YOU KNOW, GIVEN TIME --
TIME IS UNFORTUNATELY ON
RUSSIA'S SIDE IN THIS MILITARY
GAME BECAUSE THERE IS NOT GOING
TO BE A NO FLY ZONE.
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A
DEFENSE IN THE STANDARD SENSE OF
NATO COMING TO ITS RESCUE, AS IF
IT WERE AN ARTICLE V COUNTRY, A
NATO MEMBER.
AND IT WILL GET AS HORRIBLE AS
TODAY'S NEWS WAS, IT WILL
MULTIPLY AND GET MUCH WORSE.
THAT'S WHO VLADIMIR PUTIN IS AND
HE HAS BEEN FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
>> I SPOKE TO FORMER MOSCOW
CHIEF IN THE LAST HOUR TALKING
ABOUT THE NEW RUSSIAN LAW
CRIMINALIZING INDEPENDENT
JOURNALISM.
IT IS -- THE DESIRE OF VLADIMIR
PUTIN TO SUPPRESS ACCURATE
REPORTING ABOUT THE WAR, NOT
USING THE WORD WAR, USING THE
WORD INVASION.
WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU ABOUT
HIS OWN GRIP ON POWER NOW, ABOUT
HIS POSITION NOW?
>> WELL, A DESPERATE GRIP ON
POWER IS ALWAYS INNATELY
UNSTABLE.
IT'S ALWAYS THREATENED BY FROM
BELOW, WHICH PUTIN HAS ALWAYS
RECOGNIZED.
HE'S LOOKED AROUND THE WORLD AND
SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THE ARAB
WORLD SOME YEARS AGO.
HE'S SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
GEORGIA AND UKRAINE, OF COURSE.
AND THAT FEELS LIKE A THREAT TO
HIM.
CERTAINLY WHEN THERE WERE
DEMONSTRATIONS, HE SUPPRESSED
THAT.
AND HE RECOGNIZED AS THE THREAT
FROM HIS COTERIE OF LACKEYS
AROUND HIM.
I THINK THE WEST IS HOPING
YOU'LL SEE DEMONSTRATIONS FROM
BELOW, AND PUTIN IS MAKING EVERY
EFFORT, EVERY BRUTAL EFFORT, TO
SUPPRESS THE LIKES OF ALEXEI
NAVALNY, WHO IS SITTING IN
PRISON, DEMONSTRATOR WHO IS HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED, OR THE
INDEPENDENT PRESS, WHICH HAS
BEEN CRUSHED.
AND HE'S VERY WARY OF EVERYBODY
AROUND HIM.
AND YOU SAW -- HE MADE A SHOW OF
IT.
HE MADE A THEATER OF IT BY
BROADCASTING HIS MEETING WITH
THE SECURITY COUNCIL AND
HUMILIATING -- HUMILIATING --
ANYONE THAT HAD ANY CONTRARY
WORD OR SCINTILLA OF DOUBT.
AND BY THE WAY, THESE ARE NOT
DISSIDENTS.
THIS WAS -- THIS WAS THE HEAD OF
HIS FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
THAT HE MADE A POINT OF
HUMILIATING.
NOW, HOW LONG THAT CAN HOLD OUT,
WE'LL SEE.
>> DAVID REMNICK, I APPRECIATE
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> APPRECIATE YOU, ANDERSON.
THANK YOU.
>>> EVERY DAY WE'RE IN UKRAINE
IT BECOMES MORE AND MORE
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR PEOPLE HERE
TO SIMPLY BE SEEN AND HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD.
PEOPLE WANT YOU AROUND THE WORLD
TO KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
THEY WANT YOU TO SEE IT AND HEAR
IT.
THEY WANT YOU TO HEAR THEIR
STORIES, UKRAINIANS WITH
RELATIVES LIVING IN RUSSIA
TELLING THEM WHAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH ONLY TO BE TOLD BY AN
UNCLE OR FRIEND OR CLOSE FRIEND
THAT IS NOT HAPPENING AT ALL.
SO, I SPOKE WITH KYIV'S MAYOR
VITALI KLITSCHKO.
MAYOR KLITSCHKO, WHAT KIND OF
SUPPLIES DO YOU NEED IN TERMS OF
HUMANITARIAN SUPPLIES?
>> WE HAVE RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
FOOD, AND WE RECEIVE ALSO A LOT
OF MEDICATION, MEDICAL SUPPLIES
IN KYIV.
WE NEED RIGHT NOW THE PEACE IN
UKRAINE.
>> WE'VE SEEN CIVILIANS BEING
ATTACKED AS THEY'RE TRYING TO
LEAVE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT RUSSIANS
ARE TARGETING CIVILIANS?
>> YEAH, WE HAVE A LOT OF
EXAMPLE.
FOR EXAMPLE, I'M IN KHARKIV.
IT'S A CITY AROUND TEN MILES
FROM KYIV, SMALL CITY.
THE MAYOR OF GOSTOMEL BRINGS
THEM HELP TO THE PEOPLE, AND THE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS SHOOT HIM AND
KILLED HIM.
>> THERE IS STILL NOT AGREEMENT
ABOUT THE PLANES FROM POLAND
COMING TO UKRAINE.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT TO GET
PLANES?
>> WE NEED THE WEAPONS.
WE'RE READY TO DEFEND OUR
COUNTRY.
WE STAND IN FRONT OF ONE OF THE
POWERFUL ARMY IN THE WORLD, AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEED THE PLANES
ALSO VERY MUCH.
IT'S THE TIME WE DON'T HAVE TIME
TO WAIT.
IT'S MINUTES, IT'S HOURS.
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO THE
PLANES FROM POLAND TO UKRAINE.
>> THERE WERE REPORTS YESTERDAY
THAT THE RUSSIANS WERE ADVANCING
ON KYIV A LITTLE BIT FROM THE
EAST.
IS THERE AN AREA YOU ARE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT?
>> THE RUSSIANS MAKE IT PRESSURE
FROM THE EAST.
THEY LOSE A LOT OF SOLDIER AND A
LOT TANGS.
BUT I'M CONCERNED, YES, OF
COURSE, ACTIVITIES OF FROM
RUSSIAN ARMY.
BUT WE ARE PROUD OF OUR
UKRAINIAN FIGHTERS, WARRIORS,
REAL WARRIORS WHO GIVE US THEIR
FULL FOR AGGRESSORS.
>> FINALLY, THE DIPLOMAT, THE
TWO FOREIGN MINISTERS ARE
MEETING TOMORROW.
ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC SOMETHING MAY
ACTUALLY COME FROM THAT?
>> WE HOPE.
WE -- EVERYBODY HOPE IT WILL BE
A DIPLOMATIC SOLUTION IN THIS
WAR.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW JUST ONE WAY THE
RUSSIANS HAVE TO GO AWAY.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO FIND A
SOLUTION IF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ALREADY DIED.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
COUNTRY DESTROYED.
THE ECONOMY OF COUNTRY HERE HAVE
HUGE DAMAGE.
AND BY THE WAY, WE HAVE HOPE TO
STOP THE WAR, TO STO